il cessera les matins vendit puis
afrique et infirmières les semaines de
l'agente immobilière chantal albert sont
surchargés ici c'est des gens que c'est
ça des jeunes qui déneigent de l'ontario
puis essentiellement ayant acheté sont
en ligne avec une tournée virtuelle avec
l'aide de l'argent mais ils déménagent
ici au mois de juin puis on jamais
visité la maison
c'est aussi à distance que tout s'est
réglé pour la famille blais le
télétravail permet aux deux
fonctionnaires fédéraux de déménager de
gatineau à dieppe coûts et leurs maisons
au québec s'est vendues en 24 heures
leur nouveau nid est actuellement en
construction le même projet aurait coûté
beaucoup plus cher à gatineau
selon l'association canadienne de
l'immeuble le prix moyen des propriétés
au nouveau brunswick s'établissait à 181
12000 dollars en 2020
un an plus tard il est passé à 2 153
milles dollars un bond de 32%
la hausse la plus élevée de toutes les
provinces canadiennes
un prix nettement plus bas que la
moyenne canadienne qui est de 716 1000 $
et moins violent que la demande tout de
suite c'est que les gens vraiment ils
vont être compétitif puis souvent ces
gens là aussi parce qu'ils aient des
gens qui venaient marché là sont
habitués de jouer cette carte ils
offrent ils vont dire regarde muzaton
viennent un marché qui on avait une
vingtaine d'offres s'éclater maquette
c'est sous une dizaine et qui sort
habitués qui vont vraiment et guise et
leur créant la proximité avec la mer et
les grands espaces attire des acheteurs
d'ailleurs au canada ce qui nuit à la
population locale
phénomène qu'a vécu l'île du prince
édouard les jeunes locaux ils ont la
difficulté que l'état soit entrée dans
le marché pour la famille blais il
s'agit d'une bonne affaire surtout
qu'ils se rapprochent de ceux qu'ils
aiment les enfants compte les dodos
d'ici le déménagement prévu à la mi
juillet et si monde montambault
radio-canada moncton